- You recently performed in your hometown,
so, when you do a show,
'cause you've had so many hits,
there's so many things
people wanna hear you sing,
but is there one that
you still love doing?
Like, is there a favorite song of yours?
- Well, in reference to
Memphis, playing the show there,
that was the first time
we played "Selfish."
- So that made that special.
- You were there?
Oh my gosh.
- I flew there without
having tickets and I got in.
- Wow.
- I still have the bracelet on.
- [Justin] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, when I found
out you were performing,
I literally booked the
flight, booked hotels,
not knowing I was getting in.
- And that's why we
have careers, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- I live in Jersey.
- Did you have a good time?
- Amazing time, I still
have the bracelet on.
I can't take myself to, and-
- [Justin] Wonderful.
- And I found out I was
coming here yesterday.
- Did you know he was
gonna drop the new single?
- Yes, I mean-
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- All the subliminal
messaging on your TikTok,
we tried to figure it out.
- Little Easter eggs.
I like it, I like it
- We're like CIA agents, but
yes, it was unbelievable.
And I can't wait to-
- Well, as we say in
Memphis, thanks for coming.
- Thanks for coming.
- Unbelievable, I'll do it all over again.
- Come on back any time you want.
- Well, so you did the
new song there, "Selfish",
but what's one of your favorite,
like I always still love-
- From the catalog?
- Doing "Miss Independent".
Yeah, I always love doing that song.
- [Justin] You love
doing "Miss Independent"?
- It's my first single
and I don't know why,
I love it live, I love it Live.
(audience cheering)
Do you have a favorite?
- I mean, "Rock Your Body"'s fun still.
♪ Rock your body ♪
- Yeah, I like that one.
- "Mirrors".
"Mirrors" is still fun to sing.
Although sometimes I'm like,
why did I write this in this key?
It's very high.
- [Kelly] That's what I say a lot.
- Yeah, that's why I don't go
on stage until like 9:00 PM
- Yeah.
Your (singing high pitch) isn't there yet?
- It's not there yet.
- Not there yet.
- [Kelly] What do you,
this is a real question.
- What a great impersonation, by the way.
(audience laughing)
- I was trying to do my
falsetto in my head voice,
and I was like "Don't suck."
- I enjoyed it.